Hello everyone.
Thank you so much for coming.
I,
it's really lovely to see you.
I'm incredibly excited to be here.
If anyone is hiring a fiction writer here at Google,
please email me.
Uh,
I like your kitchens
and I want just an endless supply of seltzer water.
That's like my absolute dream in this world.
Um,
so today I am going to be reading from her body and other parties and I wanted
to briefly talk about the collection before I started reading and I'm actually
going to read you an entire story,
which I'm extremely excited about because um,
at readings I almost never get to read an entire story and it makes me real
cranky.
I hate doing excerpts,
so I'm like very excited to give you an entire story.
I'm stoked.
I have done that in ages.
Um,
so yeah,
her body of the parties is a collection of short stories that does a lot of sort
of genre bending material or it has a lot of gender bending material.
The cool story I'm going to read you is the only sort of pure science fiction
story in the collection.
Um,
most of the stories are sort of fabulous kind of deal with like,
or sort of surrealist,
liminal fantasy,
that sort of area.
Um,
this one just happens to be my,
my science fiction story.
Um,
and I'm really interested in,
uh,
using fiction,
just sort of explore and examine questions about women's lives and then includes
sex,
gender,
um,
sort of intellectual problems that like women experience or have uniquely in
their lives.
Um,
in terms of like how do we tell stories about women that talk about mental
health without falling into traps of like say,
writing like a crazy,
a crazy woman's story or like a crazy lesbian story,
for example.
Um,
so this is just think it's really interesting to me and is really important to
me and I've been working on these stories for about five years and uh,
yeah.
And then I finally had a book's worth,
which is pretty exciting.
Um,
yeah.
So the story I'm going to be reading you today,
it's called inventory
inventory.
One girl,
we lay next to each other on a musty rug in her basement.
Her parents were upstairs.
We told them we were watching Jurassic Park.
I'm the dad and you're the mom.
She said,
I pulled up my shirt and she pulled up hers and we just stared at each other.
My heart fluttered somewhere below my belly button,
but I worried about daddy long legs and her parents finding us.
I still have never seen Jurassic Park,
I suppose.
I never will.
Now,
one boy,
one girl,
my friends,
we drank stolen wine coolers and my room on the vast expanse of my bed.
We laughed and talked and passed around the bottles.
What I like about you,
she said is your reactions.
You respond so funny to everything like it's all intense.
He nodded in agreement.
She buried her face in my neck and said like this to my skin.
I laughed.
I was nervous,
excited.
I felt like a good tar and someone was twisting the tuning pegs and my strings
were getting tighter.
They batted their eyelashes against my skin and breathe into my ears.
I moaned and rise and hovered on the edge of coming for whole minutes.
Even though no one was touching me,
they're not even me.
Two boys.
One girl,
one of them.
My boyfriend,
his parents were out of town,
so we threw a party at his house.
We drank lemonade mixed with vodka and he encouraged me to make out with his
friends girlfriend.
We kissed tentatively and then stopped.
The boys made out with each other and we watched them for a long time board but
too drunk to stand up.
We fell asleep in the guest bedroom and the guest bedroom.
When I woke up,
my bladder was tight as a fist.
I padded down to the foyer,
Yay and saw someone have knocked a vodka lemonade onto the floor.
I tried to clean it up.
The mixture had stripped the marble finish bear.
My boyfriend's mother found my underwear behind the bed weeks later and handed
them to him.
Laundered without a word.
It's weird to me how much I missed that floral chemical smell of clean clothes.
Now all I can think about is fabric softener.
One man,
slender,
tall,
so skinny.
I could see his pelvic bone,
which I found strangely sexy,
gray eyes,
wry smile.
I had known him for almost a year since the previous October.
When we met at a Halloween party.
I didn't wear a costume.
He was dressed as Barbarella.
We drank in his apartment.
He was nervous and gave me a massage.
I was nervous,
so I let him.
He rubbed my back for a long time.
He said,
my hands are getting tired.
I said,
oh,
and turn toward him.
He kissed me.
His face rough with stubble.
He smelled like yeast and the top notes of expensive Cologne.
He lay on top of me and we made out for a while.
Everything inside of me twinged pleasurably.
He asked if he could touch my breasts and I clamped his hand around it.
I took off my shirt and I felt like a drop of water was sliding up my spine.
I realized this was happening really happening.
We both undressed.
He rolled the condom down in Lumbard on top of me.
It hurt worse than anything ever.
He came and I didn't.
When he pulled out the condom was covered in blood.
He peeled it off and threw it away,
everything and be pounded.
We slept on a too small bed.
He insisted on driving me back to the dorms.
The next day in my room I took off my clothes and wrap myself in a towel.
I still smelled like him,
like the two of us together and I wanted more.
I felt good like an adult who has sex sometimes and a life.
My roommate asked me how it was,
hugged me.
One man,
a boyfriend,
didn't like condoms,
asked me if I was on birth control,
pulled out anyway,
a terrible mess.
One woman on and off again,
sort of girlfriend,
classmate from organization of computer systems,
long brown hair down to her,
but she was softer than I expected.
I want it to go down on her,
but she was too nervous.
We made out and she slept her tongue in my mouth and after she went home,
I got off twice in the cool stillness of my apartment.
Two years later,
we had sex on the gravel roof,
top of my office building four floors below our bodies.
My Code was compiling in front of an empty chair.
After we were done.
I looked up and noticed a man in a suit watching us from the window of an
adjacent skyscraper.
His hand shuffling around inside his slacks.
One woman round glasses,
red hair,
don't remember where I met her.
We got high and fucked and I accidentally fell asleep with my hand inside her.
We woke up predawn and walked across town to a 24 hour diner.
It drizzled.
The mummy got there are sandaled feet were numb with chill.
We ate pancakes are mugs ran dry and when we looked for the waitress,
she was watching the breaking news on the batter TV hanging from the ceiling.
She chewed on her lip and the pot of coffee tipped in her hand tripping tiny
brown dots on the linoleum.
We watched the news caster blinked away and was replaced with a list of symptoms
of the virus blossoming a state away in northern California.
When he came back,
he repeated that the planes were grounded.
The border of the state had been closed and the virus appeared to be isolated.
When the waitress walked over,
she seemed distracted.
Do you have people there?
I asked her and she nodded her eyes filling with tears.
I felt terrible having asked her anything.
One man,
I met him at the bar on the corner from my house we made out on my bed.
He smelled like sour wine though.
He'd been drinking vodka.
We had sex,
but he went soft halfway through because some more he wanted to go down to me,
but I didn't want him to.
He got angry and left slamming the screen door so hard.
My spice rack jumped from it's nail and crashed to the floor.
My dog lapped up and nutmeg.
Then I had to force feed them salt to make him throw up red drum.
Adrenaline.
I made a list of animals I've had in my life,
seven including two Beta fish who died within a week of each other when I was
nine and a list of the spices and far cloves,
cinnamon star,
anise,
coriander,
ginger,
cardamom pods,
one man,
six inches shorter than me.
I explained that the website I was working for was losing business rapidly
because no one wanted quirky photography tips during an epidemic.
And I had been laid off that morning.
He bought me dinner,
we had sex in his car because he had roommates and I couldn't be in my house
right then and he slid his hand inside my bra and his hands were perfect,
fucking perfect.
And we fell into the two small backseat.
I came for the first time in two months.
I called him the next day and left him a voicemail telling him I'd had a good
time and I'd like to see him again,
but he never called me back.
One man did some sort of labor for a living,
I can't remember what exactly,
and he had a tattoo of a Boa constrictor on his back with a misspelled Latin
phrase below it.
He was strong,
could pick me up and fuck me against a wall.
And it was the most thrilling sensation I'd ever felt.
We broke a few picture frames that way.
He used his hands and I dragged my fingernails down his back and he asked me if
I was going to come for him and I said,
yes,
I'm going to come for you.
Yes,
I will.
One woman,
blonde hair,
brush voice,
friend of a friend we married.
I still not sure if I was with her because I want it to be,
or I was afraid of what the world was catching all around us.
Within a year,
it's soured.
We screen more than we had sex or even talked.
One night we had a fight that left me in tears and afterward she asked me if I
wanted to fuck and untrust before I could answer.
I wanted to push her out the window.
We had sex and I started crying when it was over and she was showering.
I packed a suitcase and gotten my car and drove one man six months later,
and my post divorce Hayes,
I met him at the funeral for the last surviving member of his family.
I was grieving.
He was grieving.
We had sex in the empty house that used to belong to his brother and his
brother's wife and their children all dead.
We fucked in every room,
including the hallway where I couldn't bend my pelvis right on the hard floor,
and so I jerked him off in front of the bear linen closet in the master bedroom.
I caught my reflection in the vanity mirror as I wrote him and the lights were
off and our skin reflected silver from the moon.
And when he came at me he said,
sorry,
sorry.
He died a week later by his own hand.
I moved out of the city,
north one man gray eyes again,
I hadn't seen him in so many years.
He asked me how I was doing and I told him some things and not others.
I did not want to cry in front of the man to whom I give him my virginity.
That seems wrong.
Somehow he asked me how many I lost and I said my mother,
my roommate from college,
I did not mention that I'd found my mother dead,
nor the three days afterward I'd spent with anxious doctors checking my eyes,
my eyes for the early symptoms,
nor how I'd managed to escape the quarantine zone.
When I met you,
he said you were so fucking young.
His body was familiar,
but alien too.
He'd gotten better and I had gotten better when he pulled out an album,
suspected blood,
but of course there was none.
He gotten more beautiful in those intervening years.
More thoughtful.
I surprised myself by crying over the bathroom sink.
I ran the taps so he couldn't hear me.
One woman,
Brunette,
a former CDC employee,
I met her at a community meeting where they taught us how to stockpile food and
manage outbreaks in our neighborhood.
Should the virus hop the firebreak.
I had not slept with a woman since my wife,
but when she lifted her shirt,
I realized how much I've been craving breasts,
wetness,
soft miles.
She wanted cock and I obliged afterwards.
She traced the indents in my skin from the harness.
I confessed to me that no one was having any luck developing a vaccine,
but the fucking thing is only passing through physical contact.
She said if people just stayed apart.
She grew silent.
She curled up next to me and we drifted off.
When I woke up,
she was working herself over with a Dildo and I pretended that I was still
sleeping.
One man,
he made me dinner in my kitchen.
There weren't a lot of vegetables left from my garden,
but he did what he could.
He tried to feed me with a spoon,
but I took the handle from him.
The food didn't taste too bad.
The power went out for the fourth time that week,
so we ate by candle light.
I resented the inadvertent romance.
He touched my face when we fucked and said I was beautiful and I jerked my head
a little to dislodge his fingers.
When he did it a second time,
I put my hand on his Chin and told him to shut up.
He came immediately.
I did not return his calls.
When the notice came over the radio,
the virus had reached Nebraska.
I realized I had to go east and so I did.
I left the garden,
the plot where my dog was buried,
the pine table where I'd anxiously made so many lists.
Trees that begin with m maple Mimosa,
Mahogany,
mulberry,
Magnolia Mountain,
Ash Mangrove,
myrtle states that I lived in Iowa,
Indiana,
Pennsylvania,
Virginia,
New York,
leaving unreadable jumbles of letters and printed in the softwood.
I took my savings and rented a cottage near the ocean.
After a few months,
the landlord based in Kansas stopped depositing my checks to women refugees from
the western states who drove and drove until their car broke down a mile from my
cottage.
They knocked on my door and stayed with me for two weeks old.
We tried to figure out how to get their vehicle up and running.
We had wine one night and talked about the quarantine the generator needed
cranking and one of them offered to do it.
The other one's sat down next to me and slid her hand up my leg.
We ended up jerking off separately and kissing each other.
The generator took and the power came back on.
The other woman returned and we all slept in the same bed.
I wanted them to stay,
but they said they were heading up to Canada where it was rumored to be safer.
They offered to bring me with them,
but I joke that I was holding down the fort for the United States.
What state are we in?
One of the mask and I said Maine.
The kissed me on the forehead and turn and WBE the protector of Maine after they
left,
I only use a generator intermittently preferring to spend time in the dark with
candles.
The former owner of the cottage had a closet full of them.
One man national guard.
When he first showed up to my doorstep,
I assumed he was there to evacuate me,
but it turned out he'd abandoned his post.
I offered him a place to stay for the night and he thanked me.
I woke up with a knife to my throat and a hand on my breast.
I told him I couldn't have sex with him lying down like I was.
He let me stand up and I shoved him into the bookcase,
knocking him unconscious.
I dragged his body out to the beach and rolled it into the surf.
He came to sputtering sand.
I pointed the knife at him and told him to keep walk,
to walk and keep walking and if you ever looked back,
I would end him.
He obliged and I watched him until he was a spot of darkness on the gray strip
of shore and then nothing.
He was the last person I saw for a year.
One woman,
a religious leader for the flock of 50 trailing behind her,
all dressed in white for three days.
I made them wait around the edge of the property and after she,
after I checked their eyes,
I permitted them to stay.
They all camped around the cottage on the lawn,
on the beach.
They had their own supplies and only needed a place to lay their heads.
Leader said she wore robes that made her look like a wizard.
Knight fell.
She and I circled the camp in our bare feet.
The light from the bonfire,
carving shadows into her face.
We walked to the water's edge and I pointed to the darkness at a tiny island.
She could not see.
She slipped her hand into mine.
I made her drink more or less moonshine.
I said as I handed her the Tumbler and we sat at the table as that,
I could hear people laughing,
playing music,
children romping in the surf.
The woman's seemed exhausted.
She was younger than she looked.
I realized,
but the job was aging her.
She sipped her drink,
made a face at the taste.
We've been walking so long.
She said,
we stopped for awhile somewhere in your Pennsylvania,
but the virus caught up for us when we cross paths.
That caught up with us when we passed crossed paths with another group.
I took 12 of us before.
We got distance between us and it.
We Kiss,
keep deeply for a long time.
My heart hammering in my cunt,
she tasted like smoke and honey.
The group stayed for four days until she woke up from a dream and said she'd had
an omen and they needed to keep going.
She asked me to come with them.
I tried to imagine myself with her,
her flock following behind us like children.
I declined.
She left a gift on my gift on my pillow,
a pewter rabbit as big as my thumb.
One man,
no more than 20 floppy,
great floppy,
Brown hair.
He'd been on foot for a month.
He looked like you'd expect skittish,
no hope.
When we had sex,
he was reverent in too gentle.
After we cleaned up,
I fed him canned soup.
He told me that how he'd walk through Chicago actually through it had they'd
stopped bothering to dispose the bodies.
After a while,
he had to refill his glass before he talked about it further after that,
he said,
I went around the cities.
I asked him how far behind the virus was really,
and he said he did not know.
It's so quiet here.
He said,
by way of tuning the subject,
no traffic.
I explained no tourists.
He cried and cried and I held him until he fell asleep.
The next morning I woke up and he was gone.
One woman much older than me while she waited for three days to pass,
she meditated on a sand Dune.
When I checked her eyes and notice they were green as Seaglass,
her hair graded her temples and the way she left trip pleasured on the stairs of
my heart.
We sat in the half light of the bay window and the buildup was so slow.
She straddled me and when she kissed me the scene beyond the class pinched and
curved,
we drank and walk the length of the beach,
the damp sand making Pale halos around our feet.
She told me about her once children,
teenage injuries,
having to put her cat to sleep the day or she moved to a new city.
I told her about finding my mother,
the perilous track across Vermont and New Hampshire,
how the tide was never still my ex wife.
What happened?
She asked.
It just didn't work.
I said,
I told her about the man in the empty house,
the way he cried in the way his come shimmered on his stomach and how he could
have scooped a spare from the air by the handfuls.
We remembered commercial jingles from our respective use,
including one for an Italian ice chain that I went to at the end of long summer
days where I eat gelato drowsy in the heat.
I couldn't remember the last time I had smiled so much.
She stayed more refugees filter to the cottage through us.
The last stop before the border and we fed them,
played games with canes,
with the little ones.
We got careless.
The day I woke up in the air had changed.
I realized it was a long time coming.
She was sitting on the couch.
She gotten up in the night and made some tea,
but the cup was tipped in.
The puddle was cold and I recognized the symptoms from the television and the
newspapers and then the leaflets and then the radio broadcasts and then the
hushed voices around the bonfire.
Her skin was a dark purple,
a compounded bruises.
The whites of her eyes shot through with bread and blood leaking from the misty
beds of her fingernails.
There was no time to mourn.
I chucked my own face in the mirror.
My eyes were still clear.
I consulted my emergency list and it's supplies.
I took my bag in my tent and I got into the dinghy and I wrote to the island,
to this island where I've been stashing foods since I got to the cottage,
I drank water and set up my tent and began to make lists.
Every teacher beginning with preschool,
every job I've ever had,
every person I've ever loved,
every home I've ever lived in,
every person who's probably loved me.
Next week I will be 30 the sand is blowing into my mouth,
my hair,
the center crevice of my notebook and the sea is choppy and gray.
Beyond it,
I can see the cottage,
a speck on the far shore.
I keep thinking I can see the virus blooming on the horizon like a sunrise.
I realized the world will continue to turn even with no people on it.
Maybe it will go a little faster.
Thank you.
Okay,
so I'm happy to take questions.
If anyone has any,
one of the things that's actually what you referenced at the beginning about
like having to not write the crazy lady story or something.
Like I feel like there's always a balance that it feels more with women writers
that there's like more pressure there.
I think one of the balances that you struck incredibly was this balance between
like intimacy and honesty about oneself and not being like eat,
pray,
love,
narcissistic.
Um,
and I don't know if you could explain a little bit about like your approach
there and if it's intentional in how you handle those things.
Ooh,
that's a really good question.
I mean I'm,
I always tell my students,
you have to write the books you want to see in the world.
Like you,
you need to fill the gap.
That's not right.
And so the
book that I wanted to see in the world was I really wanted something that dealt
with,
um,
but the dealt with like the realities of,
of being a woman and in sort of our society and like having then the female body
and like dealing with that.
And so,
you know,
this book has a lot of like this,
Sarah in it,
a lot of like liquids,
a lot of guts,
a lot of sex,
a lot of fluids,
just there's a lot of stuff.
And there's also a lot of very honest discussions of things like,
um,
like the dive store in here called the resident,
which is about a woman who goes to a writing a writers colony,
an artist's colony to work on a novel and kind of like has a sort of a mental
breakdown of,
of uh,
of a sword.
And it's basically like me,
but like turned up to 11.
So like,
you know,
I was like,
this is me kind of,
but like,
it's not actually me,
it's a fictional character,
but it's like a lot of my sort of vulnerabilities and anxieties and thought
loops and all the sort of things that make up my weird brain,
like just went into her.
And something very scary about that,
right?
Like,
just like being like,
I'm gonna put this out there,
like I'm going to write all the weird shit that happens in my head on a daily
basis in a character.
People were like,
Yo,
that character is crazy.
And it's like,
oh great,
thanks.
People get really like people,
a lot of feelings about her particularly.
Um,
and I'm like,
well,
that's the person who's most like me.
So,
um,
but yeah.
And so I feel like,
you know,
I,
I just wanted,
I wanted his collection at that,
dealt with that in a way that felt honest and felt like I was,
I mean obviously like it's not,
I'm not,
I'm only one person.
Like I can only portray sort of like one
okay.
Type of experience or like one person's perception of experiences.
Um,
but yeah,
I just wanted,
I wanted that honesty.
It was really important to me to like have that sort of immediacy and
viscerality and like not,
and not sort of move around it because I feel like that's a thing people like to
do is they're like,
they get,
they get close to it and they get afraid to like go like dive in.
And I was like,
no,
I just want to like,
I just want to be in there.
Um,
so yeah,
once in a while you read something where the techs just hits you in a certain
way that couldn't be described to you and just sort of cold logic and you just
get an emotional punch and veining of the husbands.
Did she talk about the voices?
If you read the story out loud,
please use the following voices.
And the first one is me.
You as a child,
high pitched forgettable as a woman of the same and the last one is listed as
all other woman are interchangeable with my own.
And to me that was,
that was quite quite a punch just to just to hear it that way,
to hear,
um,
your experience and women's experience,
uh,
express that way.
And I would just love to hear one more you'll have to say about that.
Yeah.
So,
so did anyone here ever read like the scary stories?
Tell them the dark bucks.
Okay,
so the husbands didn't,
so if you've read my book or if you haven't,
the husband's stitches or
of a story that actually is not in that boat,
people think it is.
It's like a weird,
like false memory.
Uh,
so Alvin Schwartz who wrote those books also had another book called in a dark
dark room.
And it was actually for younger readers,
like not teens,
but like,
like it was an,
I can read buck that was like equally scary stories with slightly less
horrifying illustrations.
And that story had a,
there was a story called the green ribbon in there,
but the girls were unified around her neck and you know,
her husband is,
I was asking her about it and she won't talk to him about it.
And then on her deathbed,
he on ties in her head falls off.
Right.
So when I,
and I wanted to do like a retelling of the story in the first story in this
collection is a retelling of,
of that of urban legend.
And um,
in the Alvin Schwartz scary stories book,
there was a lot of stage directions because those stories are meant to be like
their folktales.
They're meant to be performed.
And so when I was a kid,
I was like in girl scouts and I did a lot of campfire like camping and we would
tell stories and I learned really quickly that this book was a great way of like
freaking out my fellow girl scouts and I could like read the story and they'd be
like a command at the end.
Like,
you know,
it's like,
who has my liver like that story.
And then like you could,
it would say like grabbed the person next to you,
be like you have it.
And I didn't mean it,
the fellow girl scout like cry hysterically.
And I was super into it.
Um,
cause people were like having a reaction anyway.
So I was really the idea of like having stage directions in my story,
but of course like I didn't want them to be like regular stage directions.
I wanted them to sort of have some quality that reflected like the themes of the
book or like what I wanted to talk about.
So in the opening section of that story,
I'm sort of saying like,
cause in,
in the actual scary stories book,
they'd be like,
you know,
if you read the story out loud,
like,
you know,
use a squeaky voice or a booming voice or whatever that sort of like reflects
whatever the character's supposed to be.
And I sort of wanted to kind of make a little nod to may experience,
you know,
it's like a person who consumes a lot of media,
especially like I love TV,
I love films,
but like a thing that frustrates me,
especially in genres that I love,
which is like science fiction and horror,
um,
is that female characters are often very interchangeable and completely
unmemorable.
Um,
and so I wanted her to sort of be sort of slightly referring to the fact that
like,
we sort of think of like these female characters,
like each of these,
each of the women being described in that opening section,
it's like the man of,
he's very distinctive voices and I met the women just start like they're all
sort of interchangeable.
The irony being that when I read it out loud,
it's me reading it and I'm,
it's all mine.
It's all the same voice.
Right.
Um,
but yeah,
so I think it was something I had to do,
which is like take a formal constraint or formal conceit in my work and like use
it to just create some kind of like narrative energy.
And in that case,
like making a point about like a thing I have a thought about about women in
media.
Um,
yeah.
Through my years of seeing a Carmen and her friends online on Facebook,
conversing about all manner of topics,
um,
there's some equivalent to the,
to the stages of grief,
which is my stages of disagreement with whatever Carmen and her friends have
written.
Okay.
Yeah.
Right.
Everything on this,
this
one,
which is uh,
well I don't know exactly what they are cause they made this up,
but it starts with denial.
Like I don't agree with that point.
And then it eventually comes around to agreement and not 100% of the time,
but you know,
usually,
uh,
if I sit and read and think,
um,
I realized there was a point being made that I had not fully understood before.
Um,
but one very,
uh,
interesting disagreement in the last couple of weeks was about what fiction is
four.
And um,
one writer said in an interview that,
um,
uh,
I believe,
I believe he said my fiction is not meant to be political.
Um,
I believe that.
Yes,
I know I am.
You're a controversial
and some people I think took it as his saying that no fiction should be a
political and so there's a debate about what exactly he said,
but I thought it was an interesting topic.
Um,
is there room for fiction that isn't intended to be political with the
understanding that in the end everything must,
must,
everything must be political in the end.
But you know,
if you write something that's just,
Oh you know,
here's a person in a boat who has an adventure and you're not trying to be
political about it is,
is that,
is there room for that?
And that's not,
no,
they're really good questions.
I'm going to blow up his spot because it was in the New York Times.
It's not like it's private or anything.
So Andy where who wrote the Martian and whatever his new book is called Artemis,
I think.
Um,
yeah I had this like incredibly infuriating interview in the New York Times that
just filled me with a blinding rage,
has a glossy ability to see for like a minute.
Like I was just like so stressed out by it.
Um,
there's this,
the near terms as a series called by the book where they talk to writers about
the books that they're reading.
So it's like really cool cause you're sort of getting like,
okay,
that's a writer that I like,
here's like stuff they're interested in,
books that are like important to them.
Like it's a really cool way to sort of get like a,
as a writer,
like amping other writers voices and also like helping your readers,
like kind of learn about like other books that they should be checking out that
like you,
you like,
um,
and
his answers were just,
they were very frustrating to me because he knew everybody he mentioned,
except for JK Rowling was an old white man,
most of them are dead.
There was almost zero contemporary fiction and it was all like,
as a mob,
which is like,
not bad,
but like I,
I was like,
had you not read a book in the last 30 years?
I mean,
like,
it was literally like that kind of list and um,
you know,
one woman and it's like the most famous female writer like that we have right
now.
Right.
Um,
and it was,
and it was really angry about,
and then also in the interview,
he said,
someone was like,
asked him some question and he was just like,
I don't,
my fiction is not political.
I just don't believe in like,
you know,
I just don't,
I don't want my fiction to be political answer question.
And my answer is I don't,
I don't want us,
you think it's possible.
I don't think it's possible because even thinking that you were writing that you
can write a political fiction is,
is in itself a political,
it's political,
right?
So like even a guy in about having an adventure or a person having a boat named,
like,
who is that person?
Like that's still a political choice,
right?
Of,
of a kind.
Um,
so no,
I actually don't think those things can be separated from each other.
Um,
and it's infuriating to me that he,
that he is so uncurious about his own craft and about the world,
that that is his response.
Um,
it just really,
it just really bothered me and that,
that would,
that platform and he just want to talk about like asthma,
which is like,
again,
that sounds great,
but like,
come on.
Um,
and yeah,
so,
no,
I actually don't think,
I mean,
and I love like,
I love a good,
exciting
triple B piece of art as much as the next person.
Um,
they give me a lot of pleasure,
but I also,
that's still,
it mean that like,
like I said,
I'll come away from like the stupidest movie and let's like kind of just like a,
like a,
like a very simple sort of pleasure.
I'm thinking a lot about like the choices that have been made at like every
level,
right.
And like who gets published as a political decision?
Like who is working the publisher needs work,
doesn't get published,
whose work gets amplified in certain ways,
what,
who the characters are like,
what store,
who was allowed to tell what kinds of stories you know,
like,
um,
there,
I mean these are all like really inherently,
really fraught political positions and like the idea that you can just like
write,
make a piece of art or make a story that is not political to me,
it's just utter folly and just reveals like a deep sort of misunderstanding of
like what art is.
Um,
yeah,
sorry I went to that place again like I did.
That was rough.
It was like flashing back to like reading the article.
But thank you.
It was a great question.
Yes,
it's actually similar to something I was wondering,
would love to hear about from you about sort of how,
how your work exists in the outside world,
like outside of the scope of just the work itself and how,
what people's reactions have been and what impact you've had.
Like,
um,
so I read,
I read your book a few weeks ago when I happened to be on vacation.
I've also been going through this really weird obsessed.
I have like not,
I just,
I have like one little thing that's just mine that I do in the mornings.
It's for me,
um,
sort of echoes of the Green Ribbon Story and like,
just having one thing for you,
um,
that I'm like curly rewatching the entire west wing and listening to a west wing
revisions,
which is fricking amazing.
Like you,
it sounds horrible,
but it's actually surprisingly interesting and like the show in some way,
like Aaron Sorkin being this ridiculously talented writer watching it with 2017
eyes for like a show that started filming in 1999 and how like ridiculously
chauvinistic it is.
And it's funny because some of the themes are really,
and like don't even get me started on like the racial stuff because you know,
anyway.
Um,
but like even there was this amazing moment in the first season that the,
the people that podcast go into looking back and saying where the president and
Leo are like staying there and there are heroes.
They're like,
the heroes of here is the top of the cream of the crop of the people.
And they're saying they're good boys and the things we do to women and this sort
of like acknowledgement.
Like you're,
you're,
a lot of your stories are the other side.
They're like,
yeah,
these are the fricking things we do to women.
And like hearing it from the mail,
then they're like,
Yup.
And then they go like,
say something inappropriate to a woman.
And you're like,
what are you doing?
So I totally agree that you can't separate.
Like it is hard for me to like listen to Aaron Sorkin and be like,
man,
you're brilliant.
Like why can you,
you've one strong female character and you're constantly sexually harassing her
on the screen.
Like what the,
what is wrong with you?
Um,
I'm curious how your work being such the opposite perspective and being so
strong voice in that way.
Like how does it have,
how have you found it has impacted other people and impact a sort of the
literary world that you live in?
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
the Westwind does not age well.
I've also discovered this a is,
it is true.
Um,
yeah,
you know,
the,
the sort of idea.
Yeah.
I think what's been really hard,
again,
as a person who consumes media,
like the media that I'm most interested in is in absolutely not made for me.
Like the genres that I'm interested in,
our genre is where like I am,
my demographic is like an utter afterthought.
Right?
And so
that sort of idea of like,
wow,
like I'm not even being considered in any way,
like in anything about this.
Even artists that I love.
And like,
I like Aaron Sorkin.
I love Josh Sweden.
I love,
you know,
Lars von Trier is like a filmmaker who I adore it even though,
look,
literally every film is him like taking a woman part on the screen for like
three hours,
you know,
and that's like his entire project over and over again.
Um,
and like,
it's really hard because it's like,
those are artists that like mean a lot to me whose work has meant a lot to me.
Like Buffy was really important to me,
you know,
like,
like that is a,
and I feel like,
so at some point I had to kind of come to this like sense of peace where it's
like,
okay,
like the art that I most,
not all the art that I love,
but like a lot of the art that I love is absolutely not made with me and it's in
mine.
And also at times is like actively like destructive,
um,
in,
in certain ways.
Uh,
and harmful to women for example,
or other people of color or queer people or whoever.
Um,
and so,
okay,
so that's been like a thing I had to like come to terms with.
But then in terms of my own book,
I mean I'm really lucky because like,
you know,
I,
the work that I write is like,
you know,
I was like,
I want to write a book that has like all female protagonists.
Most of them are queer.
I want lots of sex.
I'm a weird genre stuff that doesn't really have a category I want.
Like I want all these things for this book.
And I was really lucky that like I just managed to find a publisher who like
kind of got the vision of that project because I feel like,
I mean I once had a swagger rejected by an editor who's hitting this comment
where he was like,
there's just no men in this story but there are none.
And I said,
I know,
I know there are none.
It's about a mother.
I mean,
she's got sisters,
like she's got like,
there was just like,
and I was like,
I don't,
there's just,
I mean they just don't because it will lead to be mentioned.
So they did an inch in the father and I was like,
why?
Um,
and I feel like it's like that sort of reversal of perspective is like an
intense,
it's like it's a intense and people kind of deal with.
And I think the reason people respond really strongly to my book is like this
sense of like utter relief that,
um,
that that is being sort of inverted because we're just so used to seeing the
opposite.
Right.
And so in that same way that like,
you know,
I'm,
I'm also queer and like whenever I see a queer character on TV or like,
here's a song that could be thought about as like a queer song,
I'm just like all over it.
I'm like,
I will give it all my money.
I will watch it.
I will follow it because like,
I'm seeing this like teeny,
oops,
sorry.
Whew.
I'm seeing this like tiny place where I feel even slightly represented or like
Jane the Virgin is like a show that I'm,
because I'm like how many liquids you know,
that you'd see on TV?
Right.
So like there's,
when I see that I like respond to it really strongly.
Um,
and I feel like people are feeling that way about my book where they're like,
I'm seeing a thing that like I didn't see before.
I'm hungry for,
I don't even know how hungry I was.
Or maybe you didn't know how angry you are,
but like seeing it is like this really exciting thing.
Um,
so the response to my book,
and as honestly I think they'd like the political,
even though like I'm writing this book for five years,
women's life lives have always been garbage.
They continue to be garbage,
but right now it's actually really bad.
Um,
but like we're this weird political moment where like suddenly my book is like
extra weirdly relevant even though I would like that sucks.
Like I wish it wasn't like,
I wish it was less relevant.
Um,
but yes,
I think that's why people are responding so strongly to the book is because of
this,
because not only are people like I that's familiar to me from like my whole
life,
but also in terms of just like what's happening like right now sort of
politically.
Yes.
Hello.
I just want to follow up a little bit.
Um,
uh,
I'm curious about how you think about,
the,
the line between like,
you know,
here,
here are the stories that I've published so far,
um,
and,
and a book as a thing that sort of exists in of itself.
Like what,
what was the process like of,
of uh,
putting it together as a,
as a whole packet?
Sure,
sure.
I see you have this sort of story.
I haven't calendar.
I do.
Um,
yeah,
so I've been publishing fiction for a five,
five,
six years now,
look professionally.
Um,
and I publish a lot more stories that are in this book.
There's only eight stories in this book.
Um,
and it's weird because like when I was sort of talking to editors in the process
of trying to publish it,
there was someone who was sort of interested in was saying like,
well I feel like you could add all these other stories that like I know you've
published but like aren't in this in this version of the,
of the book.
And I feel like there's sort of two philosophies about short story collections.
There's either like a short story collection is like the last 15 stories you
published in the last 10 stories you published or whatever.
Or it sort of has like a strong thematic heart and like a strong sort of
thematic link.
Um,
and for me,
I,
when I reach to our collections,
I prefer the latter.
Like I don't like as much of random stories.
I didn't want them to feel like they're in conversation with each other in some
capacity.
So I actually,
like when I was in Grad School,
I published my distraction.
My thesis,
which had the same title as this book only had three common stories where this
book,
and there's a lot of other stories that are like,
since like retired and the like the Disney vaults,
like I've tied them away and like no one will ever see them.
Um,
but I,
I wanted it because I sort of realized like,
Oh wow,
like these,
some of these stores have really like,
and other stories,
like it's something I don't like them or like they're not really like there are
about something else.
Like they're not about like women's bodies and sex.
Like there,
there was a gender and they were like,
themes that I have with this book and this like that.
I wanted it to,
the stories to be a part of.
And um,
if they fell outside of those parameters,
I was like,
well,
that's for another book or mean just like a one off story that like is not going
to go in a book.
Um,
and what's really interesting about that is like,
as I was wrapping this book up,
I sort of was writing brand new stories.
I was realizing like,
Oh wow,
like I have a second book in me.
Like I have like another set of interests that like is related to these stories,
like in,
in certain ways,
like still lots of sex,
still queer women,
like et Cetera.
But like I have like different interests.
Like I'm writing this book now that have the word,
like memory is like a very central theme.
And like that's not really a thing that exists in here,
but like,
it's like this new idea that I'm having.
And so it's actually pretty cool because I feel like when you're,
when you're trying to put together a debut book,
it's like,
that's your focused,
or like,
this is the,
this is,
this is my book,
this is the thing in my brain.
And then you have it and you're like,
oh,
I had like other books in my brain about other things.
And it's like a very odd feeling when you've been really focused on publishing a
book for like your whole life.
Um,
so,
so yeah.
So I just like,
I,
so now I have like a new projects and um,
these stories just get my,
my,
my editor really wanted like a tight lean collection.
Two of these stories are really huge.
Like the resident and especially heinous are,
are massive.
Um,
and so yeah,
it's when it's been like two novellas,
six store,
six short stories,
it's like a fairly average sized collection.
Um,
yeah.
And I just didn't want to add anything else to at least felt like they were very
tight and sort of in competition with each other.
Um,
so yeah,
so that's why,
but I,
I really like the result.
Like I feel like this was the book I needed to be.
I'm glad I didn't publish it as earlier versions of it with like more stories
and let that weren't as connected.
Um,
so I was curious when for you or what was the book when you first felt like you
saw yourself or presented?
Um,
oh,
like that I read that you read.
Yeah.
Like,
and when that happened in your life and how long it took for that to happen?
For me,
it took a while.
I was a teenager,
so.
Great.
Yeah,
I mean,
I mean it happens,
there have been bits and spurts sort of through out.
So like,
I mean,
I was a voracious reader as a teen.
I read like a lot of books.
I mean books like,
I mean it was assessed with a lot of like red,
like Anna Morris.
I get all of those and I rapped me,
I read a lot of like series.
Um,
but I really loved like a wrinkle in time.
Like,
you know,
like that,
that was like a really formative book for me.
Um,
uh,
I mean,
I didn't really get to read.
Maybe I grew up in the 90s,
so like I wasn't really reading many books about like queer teens,
but it would be like,
in terms of like female voices,
like I was getting a lot of,
there was like behind the attic wall,
which was like a novel.
That was really important to me.
Oh,
you know it,
it's so good.
It's so good.
Okay.
We can talk after.
We can talk about that because it's,
it's so good.
Um,
whenever I say to people who know it,
they get like incredibly excited.
It's such a good buck.
So that was like a really formative book for me.
Um,
where I,
I,
I mean like every teenager and every like preteen,
it feels like,
oh,
I'm so gawky awkward.
No one likes me.
So it's like easy to identify character in a book because you're like,
they're all like gawky and like hard,
you know,
it,
they're like,
oh,
I have problems making friends.
It's like,
yeah,
we all do like welcome to the club.
Um,
yeah.
And then as I got older,
I mean the work that sort of really kicked off my,
my contempt,
what I call it,
thinking about my sort of my voice or I felt like I was reading work that I
wanted to respond to you with my own work,
which was like a very distinct sort of moment in my life.
I was reading people like Kelly link,
Karen Russell,
Helen.
Oh,
yummy.
George Saunders.
Um,
mostly female writers.
and yeah,
and they were all,
it was all like short stories that look like weird stuff.
And just like felt weird and like had a lot of women in them.
Then we're just like really like weird and interesting and I don't know that
those are those.
So I feel like I'm sort of multiple steps.
And then also like in high school I had this teacher who gave me,
um,
I was really at,
so she taught as a public school.
So we constantly learning like Hemingway and I really,
really hate Hemingway still to this day.
And I would just yell at every class.
[inaudible] I like every class she'd be like,
let's talk about it.
And I'd be like,
he's an alcoholic.
Like I had thoughts,
I was like,
he's horrible.
The women,
like this woman I hate,
I hate everything happening.
Oh well my mic down in my rage anyway.
Um,
and I was really mad and she stopped calling on me through.
I would retire cause I'd be like my hand be like furiously raising it there and
she'd be like,
Carmen,
I don't even want to hear you say about or something way.
Um,
but she could tell that I was frustrated by like what we had to read it,
what we were reading in school.
And like we only ever read like one book by a woman,
like my entire,
we read Jane Eyre and that was like,
Eh,
and then everything else was fine.
So like I was very frustrated even though I loved English class and I loved,
you know,
and so one day my teacher,
Ms. Dot.
Mrs Time,
Bob,
bless her heart,
came in with like a pile of books from her personal library and she's like,
I think you will like these,
like you need to read them.
And it was a hundred years of solitude but can't be like Garcia.
Mark Has Gloria,
Gloria Naylor's Mama Day.
Um,
Henry James is what Maisie new,
um,
uh,
Kate Chopin's the awakening.
Um,
I'm like a handful of others and it was just like,
and I suddenly was also like able to like just see what sort of possible in
literature and like what it was like to sort of write from all these different
places and like,
I don't know,
like it just really liked.
So I feel like I had this like stages of like self discovery as a young person
in terms of what I was reading,
this very directed thing that happened to me like in high school.
And then when I was in Grad School,
I had a lot of friends who were sort of like,
you need to be reading these people because like it's in,
but that's what you want to be doing as a writer.
And then I felt like my mind was like blown open and I was like,
oh my God,
everything is amazing.
Literature is,
um,
you know,
I was just like so exciting.
So cause I think it's been like different phases.
Um,
so you talked about
go together and
I wondered if you'd talk about the name a little,
her body and other parties.
It,
you mentioned Jane the Virgin earlier.
I feel like there's this group of subversive and thoughtful media with this sort
of like,
yeah,
I know what you think of me.
Names Jane the Virgin Crazy,
his girlfriend.
I was just,
Yup.
Yup,
Wondered if you'd talked about that all
as a great question and one that I have a lot of thoughts about.
Um,
yeah,
so I really,
it's funny,
I actually did not watch cruise yesterday,
a friend for a while because the title was so off putting to me and then someone
was like,
no,
so who knows me?
It was like,
no,
no.
You really need to watch it.
You will love it.
And I,
and I did.
And I think it's like one of the best shows on television right now.
I absolutely love it.
I'm doing the version also.
I was like,
what a weird title for a show.
Um,
but yeah,
and so,
I mean,
this story collection,
there's a few reasons.
So,
um,
I wanted,
I asked her friend how do people named short story collections and they were she
and he was like,
well oftentimes it's like the title of one of the stories,
but it's like a title that sort of embodies the themes of the,
of the bowl book.
And you'll notice if you read your story cloths and you'll notice that like,
usually the title is like a title of one of the stories.
Um,
but none of the titles were working for me in that capacity.
Like I was looking at all the towels,
I was like,
none of these feel like a book title.
And I love titling things.
It's like a hobby,
a weird hobby I have.
Um,
so yes,
I was sort of thinking about it and then I also,
excuse me,
it was thinking about,
um,
so this book that I really love Ted Chiang's story of your life and others,
which is a book which if you haven't read,
you absolutely must cause it is literally perfect.
And Ted Chiang's a genius since science section and it's gorgeous and amazing.
Um,
but he,
uh,
so that,
that title has that sort of Pun,
right,
where it's like stories of your life,
which is the name of one of his stories and others it can be like,
and other lives are and other stories,
right?
So using that sort of structure of like and other stories sort of riffing on
that structure.
So then I had that in mind.
Um,
and then I started kind of mashing my titles together.
So I was just sort of like,
let's see like what words,
like keywords for my titles,
my story titles could like be put together in this,
in this structure.
Um,
and then I came up with I think like,
um,
but like bodies and other parties because like real women have bodies is like,
that's in the title.
And then it was like,
but I feel like I want the agenda,
I want the gender element to be in there.
So then I was like her body,
her body and other,
her body and other parties and like,
I just really liked it.
And then it just stuck.
And I've,
it's been,
and he's been the title of his book even before this book was like even remotely
looked like this.
Um,
and I feel like it also helped me because it was having kind of work toward
like,
it was like a light,
like a light house that I can sort of like be moving toward with like my work
and the way I do my edits.
Um,
so yeah.
Uh,
that was just,
I mean that was just like how I kind of came to it.
Um,
but has a really important and yeah,
I do think that sort of quality of like,
fuck you for what you think of me.
Right.
Like that title.
It's like such a good,
it's really fun.
And I think that sort of level of some version is a,
is really and really interesting.
And I think there's thing that both,
those are both those examples that you gave are like female driven,
like PR a properties,
one of whom was like a woman of color like that there.
I think that's like important,
but that sort of very,
very self aware title.
Um,
so yeah,
that's it.
Yeah.
All right.
Well,
thank you so much everyone who was,
well,
we've talked to you.